this video is sponsored by nebula watch
my exclusive podcast episode about
asteroid City only on nebula
Emma created expressly for this
broadcast Wes Anderson has been breaking
the fourth wall from very early on in
his career I mean very literally there
are many moments where he just takes the
fourth wall out of the set so it's no
surprise to find him doing it again in
Asteroid City here there are three walls
and there's a character standing on this
side of where the fourth wall should be
looking straight at the audience but
asteroid City doesn't just break the
fourth wall it kind of shatters it
entirely it makes it difficult to
understand where the fourth wall in the
story even is or if there even is one it
doesn't start inside the narrative and
then break out of the fourth wall it
starts outside of the fourth wall and
then kind of moves into the narrative
and back out and all over the place
am I not in this asteroid city is Wes
Anderson at his most narratively and
structurally Abstract so far I hadn't
planned it that way he just sort of did
it while I was typing is it too
extraordinary for you ironically it
seems like it's within this surreal
poetic narrative limbo that he finds the
freedom to be the most direct he's ever
been about his own personal approach to
life and art all that matters is every
second of Life on stage and our
friendship I want to talk about why I
love this movie so much and why I think
it's surreal chaotic Maze of meta
structure actually serves a purpose
I still don't understand the play
what is asteroid City about 73 minutes
into the movie The play's writer gives
us an answer
infinity and I don't know what else but
that's what asteroid City the fictional
play Within the movie within the TV show
The One written by Conrad Earp and
directed by Schubert green is about what
is the one written and directed by Wes
Anderson that we see when we go to the
theater about the list of themes and
ideas that asteroid city is exploring is
almost as long as the list of names on
the movie's poster if we look very
literally at what's on the surface we
can see that asteroid City touches on
loss grief America storytelling the
entertainment industry stardom
quarantine aliens and
I don't know what else but I think the
biggest thematic question in the movie
Explorers the one that underscores
everything is what's the cause
what's the meaning out of nowhere what
are those pulses indicate what's that
what was that was I ever there
meaning in both life and the creation of
art why does Augie burn his hand on the
quickie riddle
I think if I had to say what I think
asteroid city is about I'd say I think
it's about what it feels like to feel
uncertain about everything to be
surrounded by a chaotic world that
doesn't offer a break from that
uncertainty and most relevant to our
current time what it feels like to
suddenly be cast into that uncertainty
by an outside event outside of your
control like a quarantine
but maybe we're getting ahead of
ourselves where are we Connie and when
talk to us okay so in the movie there's
the black and white portion about the
making of the play and there's the play
itself which we see in color here we are
inside the play War photographer Augie
steenbeck and movie star Mitch Campbell
sit in their separate houses under
government mandated quarantine chatting
about life and Parenthood and how it
relates to their work when suddenly the
conversation takes a turn I think I see
how I see us
I mean I think I know now what I realize
we are okay she starts analyzing the
relationship from a very meta
perspective too catastrophically wounded
people who don't express the depths of
their pain because
we don't want to this line does pretty
accurately describe what's going on with
their characters and this is maybe
something an actor would say to somebody
else as they were getting to know them
but it mostly sounds like something you
would say if you were analyzing the the
subtext or motivation of this
relationship and these characters it
kind of sounds like something a writer
or an actor would say during the
pre-production of a film or a play
that's a little weird but it doesn't end
there also notice how nidge mentions
that her black eye isn't real because
her character doesn't get a black eye in
the story it's Grace paint to feel like
my character
Technically she's talking about the
character she's preparing to play in the
script she's working on but this
statement also explicitly applies to the
character of Midge Campbell in Asteroid
City these little moments are ways that
Anderson is breaking and removing the
fourth wall not visually but in the
writing it brings our attention back to
the fact that when we're watching a play
or a movie We're not just watching the
characters we're actually simultaneously
watching the characters and the actors
playing the characters in fact in my
opinion you didn't just become Augie he
became you I think it's kind of tempting
to think about the black and white
portions of this film as kind of
decorative framing for the real story
which happens during the play in the
color portions but if we remove the
fourth wall between these two fictional
layers it collapses into One Singular
story with the same characters the
entire way through we have to remember
as the host of the TV show tells us that
both the real world portion of the story
and the play are fictional as a part of
a television program about the creative
process and talking about the creative
process Wes Anderson is showing us how
the writer director and actors lives
influence their work subtextually even
if it's not a direct connection there's
an emotional or personal one that is
connected because the actor and the
character are literally the same person
that's kind of what our attention is
being drawn to here this sameness
between the actor and the character is
highlighted with certain lines take for
example when Jeff Goldblum who is
playing the alien is asked what the
alien is a metaphor 4 he says this I
don't know yet we don't pin it down this
mixing of tenses in this line is making
it sound like his character is saying he
doesn't know yet because he's still
waiting on an answer but the actor is
saying on another level maybe
accidentally that we don't pin it down
because he's read the script and he
knows that they do never come up with an
answer in the story that he's a part of
you can kind of get the same thing in
this moment where Auggie burns his hand
on the quickie griddle and Mitch
Campbell says you really did
that actually happened it's almost like
her character knew it was gonna happen
but is surprised when it actually does
in the story I don't know how to explain
this exactly but it's just this weird
Fusion where it feels like the actor is
alive in the story and the story is
really happening it's it's a bizarre
effect but it feels very intentional to
me part of the subtext of these scenes
is that Midge Campbell and Auggie
steenbeck are actually just the actors
Mercedes Ford and Jones Hall the entire
time but the subtext of that subtext is
that they're both actually just Jason
Schwartzman and Scarlett Johansson the
entire time or just I didn't think of
that I again
I didn't think of that I should have
when we're watching asteroid City what
we're really watching is Jason
Schwartzman playing Jones Hall playing
Auggie steenbeck saying what his
character says which was written by
Conrad Earp which was written by Wes
Anderson and you can start to see how
the alternate title of the play was the
cosmic Wilderness by erasing these lines
between reality and fiction or maybe
fusing them together the movie explores
the question of the meaning of life and
meaning in art simultaneously
are we playing our characters right am I
performing Thomas flight correctly is
Wes Anderson performing Wes Anderson
correctly if we're in a play who's
directing it
and is the director happy with how it's
all going
you men should be ashamed of yourselves
are you
you can't wake up if you don't fall
asleep
so you're in a play and you're playing a
character but you don't always know why
your character does the things that they
do so you want to understand your
character's motivation because you want
to know what it all means and you want
to do it right this is our chance to be
actually worthwhile in our lifetimes I
see what you mean and while you're
trying to figure all this out the world
around you is kind of bubbling with
Insanity things that are really
happening shootouts quarantines children
with weapons bombs dropping all feel
kind of distant and unreal a suddenly
jarring event might make it difficult to
just go on with your life as if nothing
happened even while you're maybe feeling
like you should maybe be feeling more
about these things than you do you feel
different
well I don't feel anything at all
me neither strangely in this movie The
behind the scenes portion the part that
in theory should be closer to real life
looks more like a play and is presented
in black and white it's here in the
interior of the play asteroid City
itself even through all the layers of
meta-framing devices and visual artifice
that you might still forget for a moment
that you're watching a play in a movie
where you might forget as we often do
watching stories that you're watching
anything at all where a character stops
being a character and starts to feel
like a person with real emotions he's
your grief
and often the way that writers and
actors produce this effect for the
viewer is by tapping into their own
actual life experience and personal
emotions what Anderson is kind of
getting at here is that those moments
that feel real and true through all the
layers of fiction are actually real and
true because often as the viewer what
you're connecting with is not the
character but the truth of the actor or
writer's emotions or experiences that
just happen to be coming through all of
those layers there's a reality
Underneath It All That is making it feel
real it's when we let our hyper rational
thinking mind fall asleep and allow
ourselves to dream
when we let go of the need for concrete
explanations and our need to really
understand
that we can wake up to something that
feels real within the story oh wow
I think this is true within the creation
of art but perhaps it's also true about
life
I don't know to be honest I'm tired this
has been a long week I don't know if
this video is really making that much
sense or conveying what I'm trying to
convey about this film and the reality
is this whole movie is a fabrication so
there's no concrete objective
explanation of the film that I can
discover and then give to you here but
to make the fabrication that is asteroid
City the artists working on this movie
tapped into their own real emotions and
life experiences and sometimes I think I
can sometimes feel that coming through
the screen and it feels like Auggie
steenbeck is really in grief even though
I know it's just Jason Schwartzman the
whole time and it feels like the
personal life experience that Anderson
is trying to convey through this movie
is that sometimes when you're trying to
do something whether it's a creative
project or just life
you might not know if you're doing it
right you might not know why something
happened or even why you did something
and when you feel like that sometimes
you have to just keep doing the work
because your cue is coming up and you're
wanted back on stage
just keep telling the story
you're doing them right okay stop
some people feel like all this meta
Framing and Anderson's visual style
pushes away the emotion of the film and
makes everything feel more distant and I
discussed kind of the ins and outs of
this with Tom from the channel like
stories of old for our podcast Cinema of
meaning it comes back to this whole idea
of like this now two explicit actors
talking about their fictional characters
who right could have had this emotional
moment but didn't and yet them talking
about the potentiality of that still
felt to me like the most
relevant or the most emotionally
resonant moment of the movie for me you
can watch or listen to this bonus
episode of Cinema of meaning exclusively
on nebula a creator-one streaming
service where you can find all my usual
content early and without any ads or
sponsor reads as well as a bunch of
other exclusive content from myself and
other creators sign up right now with my
link to get a special discount check out
those videos and then check out all the
other great content from creators on
nebula like stuff from Patrick H Willems
Jacob Geller and even Lindsay Ellis who
now creates content exclusively for
nebula you also get access to nebula
classes where you can watch great
classes on film Theory from creators
like Patrick and Tom as well as a
variety of other subjects from other
great creators you'll also find stuff
like jet lag a show that I really love
and always watch when it airs early on
nebula the great thing about nebula is
that when you sign up using my code and
watch stuff there it directly supports
my channel allowing me more freedom to
do different kinds of projects and
pursue bigger more
stuff while giving you direct Early
ad-free Access to all the content I make
it's a very affordable service starting
at just 250 a month when you use my code
for the annual plan it has great apps
for iOS Android Google TV Roku and more
so you can easily watch the videos
wherever you want click the link in the
description below to watch the entire
discussion I had with Tom about asteroid
City and to support my channel and other
independent creators today
[Music]
thank you